what is going on citizens of the reject
Nation this is my favorite news out of
DC since Christopher Nolan's Batman
Trilogy this is my favorite bit of DC
news since I have started talking about
comic books this is DC getting their
Kevin feigees this is the hierarchy of
power changing as The Rock promised this
is how DC builds a powerful platform and
foundation and shared universe and TV
and everything we want this is James
Gunn and Peter Safran becoming the heads
of now DC Studios that's right it is no
longer DC films it is not quite the DC
EU since it never really was they
changed that name a few times DC Studios
is now run by two Titans now before we
get into it please do leave a like in
this video leave a comment let me know
what you think of this excellent
excellent news my bias might be part of
this journey you'll know what I think of
it immediately and please do want me
down on Tick Tock I'm gonna be reporting
on this as things develop you get 15
seconds 30 second one minute long
breakdowns of comic books and movie news
and this is the Zenith I am so very
excited let's get into it
[Music]
now let's kick it off with James Gunn I
am going to talk about Peter Safford in
a second because I think that guy is
being slept on as far as trending we'll
get to him in a minute but James Gunn we
have to acknowledge how insane this is
how many different Butterfly Effects had
to occur for this very specific event to
happen not only is he as a filmmaker one
of the boldest filmmakers in the game he
is always taking big broad swings and
chances which is a great sign for what
DC has to come not only is a big big big
comic book fan in that he loves the most
obscure character he can also make you
love the most obscure character how
excited are you for Cosmo after the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
how much do you love king shark how much
is Rocket Raccoon part of your life
these are not characters that are known
he knows how to make the underdog work
as well as the weird comic thing work
he's also someone who's good at World
building go back to 2008 you've got Iron
Man starting and then you've got a bunch
of superheroes that are not well known
but they're at least known then a couple
years later not that far in you've got
James Gunn doing Guardians of the Galaxy
now I'll totally own I was one of the
people that was worried I was like oh is
this the first taste of Disney buying a
thing is this a talking tree in a
raccoon is this toys I was really
worried that's what happened and then I
saw what James Gunn did with these
characters and I was so aware that in
that case the hierarchy of Marvel had
just changed he was able to make a
cosmic movie totally realigned what I
think Marvel had been originally
planning because of how much we loved
that Cosmic Family how much we loved
that bunch of [ __ ] that changed
Marvel he is a World Builder in his own
right so what had to happen was he had
to make Guardians of the Galaxy it had
to do so shockingly well that years
later it would be cited as the reason
that the suicide squad got effectively
re-edited from the movie it was going to
be with David Ayer to the trailer that
was edited for Comic-Con and then
reshaped to be the trailer that was
effectively a James gun tone and then he
would have to get fired from Disney and
then hired at DC to make the Suicide
Squad movie they had apparently always
wanted that then did exceedingly well
especially for an already movie opening
in a pandemic gotta spin off with
Peacemaker because it was so critically
acclaimed as well as people watching it
then got rehired at Disney to not only
finish his own Trilogy of Guardians of
the Galaxy but also make a spin-off
which we just got the trailer for with
the holiday special and all of that
being a sense of World building that led
him to be one of the architects of
infinity war and in game one of the
brain trusts that was beholden to making
what the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
while homeboy was working on DC's shared
universe so this is the perfect example
of how you build out DC he knows Comics
he knows bold choices with movies and he
knows World building he's going to be
able to do what Kevin feige does and do
it Pizzazz do it on stage present in
Hall h make comic fans invested and he's
one of us just like Kevin feige is under
that hat Kevin feige is a ride or die
nerd that knows and cares about what
panel of what issue things are happening
on so is James Gunn James Gunn knows the
Obscure stuff from the 70s the weird
esoteric of the sixth the strange crime
ridden of the 70s and 80s then you get
into the crazy image of the 90s the guy
has been there through it all he's got
the receipts he's going to make the DC
Universe the greatest hits of DC like it
needs to be the thing that Marvel does
best is they look at Giant swaths of
comic book 10 years and then they
consolidate it into like Now That's What
I Call Music of the comic books James
Gunn does that and arguably does it with
even more obscure characters so everyone
that's been concerned about the future
of Batman the future Superman they
shouldn't be because this man already
knows those and he's going to make your
booster golds in your Blue Beetle sing
he's going to be the one that cares
about the Blue Beetle movie as much as
the Superman movie but he's not gonna
stop Superman from happening and he is
surely not gonna take his head off he
will be seen with a face at all times
Henry cavill's back that's the face of
Superman and James Gunn knows it this is
literally the best case scenario now
let's talk about Peter saffron we need
to acknowledge how great a move this is
to have Peter Safran as well now when
you look at the things that are working
with Marvel they've got a very very
singular entity in Kevin feige a
producer like we've never really had
before because these three things he's a
showman he's an excellent exceptional
top of the line producer and he's a ride
or die comic book junkie now when you
combine James Gunn and Peter Safran who
are both excellent producers so there
you go you solved the producer issue
James Gunn is a genius of comic book
lore and an excellent showman and then
you've got an on-site genius creative
producer in Peter saffron so you've got
a great behind the scenes producer in
James Gunn a great on the day on set
available very Hands-On producer and
Peter saffron and both are giant comic
book fans and then you've got the
Showmanship of James Gunn this is the
Frankenstein feige I've dreamed of I can
see it now we've got halt h with James
Gunn coming out on stage and introducing
people you've got Peter saffron who's on
set even on movies that James Gunn's
directing you've got this man who I'm
talking about saffron here still who is
so Hands-On that he was one of the key
figures in making sure The Peacemaker
show happened in spinning off of The
Suicide Squad I'm going to totally own a
behind the scenes moment right here I
did press on Shazam and I toured with
Shazam I love Shazam so much that I was
with it in New York California Hawaii I
was with the cast I took two of them
comic book shopping Shazam was my baby
and at every turn I was so impressed at
how Hands-On Peter saffner was how
important The Fan Experience was to him
how much he wanted to know how much we
saw in the lore how much he knew about
the Shazam lore which frankly let's be
honest Shazam is not a well-known
quantity and how much he was happy that
the actors were so invested and then I
actually ran into the guy not that long
ago he recognized me on the streets in
Burbank and we had a great conversation
about Peacemaker and about how much he
wants certain things to happen in DC not
going to talk about that on there
because I hope they happen but the guy
was so invested in my experience as both
a journalist a fan a comic book junkie
he wanted to know what I thought of this
decision and he was so in love with
Peacemaker he was so giddy about what
had been done with Peacemaker that gives
me hope in the DC Universe going forward
so we've got this Frankenstein I talked
about we've got the producer comic book
and showman all on stage in these two
and we've got Peter Safran being I have
only heard amazing things about as far
as what he's like on set this is a man
that turns small budget movies into
large budget successes he got his
starting horror he's done a bunch of
very bold things like Ryan Reynolds
buried and then he went on to make sure
Aquaman made its billion dollars made
Shazam for pennies on the dollar for
what superhero movies cost and that did
well so that's what we need right now we
need a director and a producer that are
both good at making this much money into
this much money because right now if you
haven't noticed that's what DC is
struggling with they're looking at how
to leverage the money they have and
rebuild from the ground up so you've got
two guys that can do that and best of
all they're comic book fans and even
better of all they care about our
opinion I don't know anyone outside of
the many aforementioned times Kevin
feige that loves the fans so publicly so
directly as much as the issue honestly
this is the best case in order for you
PC DC is in the best sets of hands it
could be and the future of DC is looking
bright this feels like when you're
reading a Superman comic and you turn
the page and you see him flying outside
the planet and everything's like birds
are chirping things are saying this is
how I feel about DC right now I am a
giant DC Comics fan I have wanted DC
Comics to have a a Stranglehold on
movies in so many ways for so long it
only makes Marvel work harder it only
makes DC fans have a place to feel
welcome and it only makes both universes
better and that only leads to better
films if DC makes Bold chances then
indie films can make Bolder chances
because movies will be doing like Rising
tide lifts all boats is what I'm saying
I appreciate each and every one of you
I'm Overjoyed at this news James Gunn
you're the best Peter Safran thank you
so much for caring DC you're in good
hands and I cannot wait to be along for
the ride you guys better ready for like
800 percent more DC content because your
boy is in let's get it
[Music]